how do you feel about it being the 20th
anniversary of smallville does it does
it kind of do you think about that do
you think like holy
what do you think about
time goes by really fast
yeah it sure doesn't mean yeah it just
goes by so
i think that's mostly and with the
pandemic too because it all happened at
the same time
these year the year and a half of the
pandemic went by so quickly and then
having the
you know because we didn't there was no
real differentiation in the days that
all kind of blurred together into this
one
massive time that just was like what has
already been a year and a half already
and then with the 20-year anniversary i
was like
it just goes by so quickly
yeah you know do you miss anything about
it is there anything you missed that you
think back you know i really had fun
doing this i i miss this person i miss
this sort of camaraderie
i'm you know i missed working with tina
thioli and
i miss
joking around with steve oben and i miss
having steve was our wardrobe guy who
just uh let's just say steve was a a
great energy on set and spoke his mind
and would just tell it like it is
he did he did it indeed i remember him
walking in the trailer and go here's
your shirt and i'm like uh i don't
really like it because i don't care they
told me to give it to you just you can
wear it or you don't have to i don't
really give a
that is pretty much dead we were young
we were young and eager and
you know i was i just remember it it
just feels like it was so long ago
it really does feel like it was long a
long time ago it's like another lifetime
it is weird but what do you think about
when you're 70 or 80 and people saying
they just they remember smallville
that's what is that okay with you is
that does that bother you do you want to
be known for something else do you do
you hate talking about smallville no i
don't hate talking about it i also
will people remember i hope that the
substance of my life isn't measured by
things that people remember me for in
the general public
like i'd like the substance of my life
to be
smaller if that makes sense and deeper
how do you want to be remembered yeah
i i don't know i've never i've honestly
never thought about how i cause i'll be
dead
but i do i want to have
built meaningful relationships and
made some sort of positive impact on
those closest to me
i think that's it i don't